[Applause]
[Music]
in a ramshackle corner of a war
ravaged state there is a noisy place
called sunlight primary where the sound
of hope
rises from its corrugated classrooms
the facility is overcrowded with three
or four pupils per desk
and the teachers are paid just a few
pennies a day
but the children are making plans at
this school in south sudan
what would you like to be what kind of
job would you like sometimes
there are 700 pupils studying at this
school
and the teachers are looking to britain
for help
but cuts to the uk aid budget have hit
sunlight primary hard have you had any
teacher training
the problem that i face also i'm still a
student
you're still a student yourself
most of the teachers at this school are
in their late teens
and they haven't done any training in
fact these teachers haven't finished
high school
themselves and it was clear they were
struggling
in classes with 50 pupils or more
some found alternative ways to cope and
the head teacher said
he couldn't really blame them yes no
idea
no idea that's no idea because it's not
qualified
so but there is any training can be good
so that can be trained
you know training sometimes can open the
mind of the person
then you know what to do but you are not
trained on how to do things in education
then you cannot do anything a british
charity
called the windall trust set up a
program to help teachers in south sudan
obtain their high school diplomas then
begin professional training
but their funding was cut the week it
was supposed to start
would you be interested in in this
course of course me myself
i like it you want to get your high
school diploma too of course
of course i like that i like that if
that one come i will join first i will
call
with my teacher and then we go on you
will go together they are together
you like that you think that would be
good for the sunrise primary
very very nice very nice
[Music]
there's little money for schooling in
south sudan where revenues are
squandered by competing elites and the
consequences are clear
98 students left sunlight primary last
year
but only 10 went on to high school the
boys do little
says mr ai while the girls are married
off
these two gentlemen were finished here
last year
they are now here they are not going to
school i mean they're on the street yeah
that one is too
a couple of weeks ago the british
government notified south sudan
in this letter that it would be making
significant reductions
in funding however the letter says the
uk
will deliver on its commitment to put
400 000 girls into education
and improve the learning environment for
all south
sudanese children but the cancellation
of the
windall trust program looks like a clear
breach
of this commitment we really felt
demoralized
john after putting in a lot of effort
a lot of trainings we even hired some
you know
experts to help us you know to work on
the curriculum
and when we were now at that point of
beginning to take off that's when the
news came
we were really demoralized
[Music]
odds are sunlight primary will be the
only school these children
ever know with an education provided by
unqualified teenagers earning 50 pence
a month their future in school
and life curbed before it's begun
john sparks sky news in boar south sudan